[Applause]
[Music]
for this challenge
we're gonna need some mattresses
[Music]
this is the right spot for a soft
landing
[Applause]
oh no that's not soft ah
now we have a soft landing
around the net header super headshot
super headshot give me a test one i'll
do one without the dive see
practice one
[Music]
let's super match us so the next
challenge is to poke 50 holes into a
table tennis ball and see if we can
still play with it
i think this will actually fly quite
weirdly in the air
okay this is well over 50 holes but i
think it needs a bit more
just normal yeah
okay no it's
it's really normal actually it's just a
bit slower the sound is a bit weird
oh i got weird downstairs
have to be careful not to be the ball
breaker on this don't break it
[Music]
okay so that didn't bounce weird enough
so we're making more holes
and once again we're doing this so you
don't have to break your
brand new pongfinity balls when you get
them from our store before
and after let's try it
[Applause]
it's i don't know what's wrong with it
okay this is well over 50 holes it's
like there's something weird about it
it doesn't grip like it drops down
the sound is so weird can you hear the
sound
less spin less speed and a weird
weird sound that was good thanks
to the next challenge okay next let's
try and do some net serves
[Music]
one two three
four five
six
[Music]
eight
nice the one who drops out last wins
ready set go
this is intense
okay so the idea is to get one bounce
pass it over
two bounce pass it over until you miss
[Music]
oh it's still in
oh that was four no i missed counting
nice
yes
we just want to beat the record
good save
[Music]
okay for ml5
it's a really good save to get the fifth
like yeah okay
that's definitely not an easy challenge
you have to try this out see how many
you can get
and remember to check out our very own
pongfinity balls
they're professional level table tennis
balls and we use them in all of our
filming sessions
you can get them from pongfinity.store
until next time
[Applause]
it goes hard if you hit it hard